you guys the rumors are true
annie what's going on and i are dating
no not anymore
we just broke up esther and i broke up
because we're so excited about our new
name
it's trash tuesday josh tuesday baby
welcome to the garbage um
we feel like every week now you'll know
that on tuesdays there'll be a
little pile of trash waiting for you
when you smell that rot it is not crotch
it is actually us
entertaining you talking about very vile
things
just the flies swimming around us and
they do fly they do not swim but
so please find us on itunes and
rate us and review us now is the time
more important than ever
we're relaunching with our new name and
we want everyone to know that we're the
trashiest tuesday around
so find us on itunes rate review right
annie
yes and remember we will see you next
tuesday trash tuesday next tuesday trash
tuesday we will see you next trash
tuesday i just want to say
that there has never been a more fitting
name
for three disgusting garbage bags old
sperms
we're a little and the people listening
are the slugs in the garbage with us
and your trash bags honestly are just
trash bags just like us
you're one of us something is wrong with
you
why are you here why are you here
we need you we're nothing without you
don't take off your your sunglasses
because i feel like lasers are going to
shoot out of there because you seem like
you're heated i'm
heated the audience needs to see the
heat
i want to see it'll be
now it took an hour and 20 minutes to
get here the traffic was the most
annoying type of
traffic where every time you got into a
lane that was moving dead stop
then i'm coming up on uh towards your
house i'm not going to say where you
live also i can't say
because they're going to find me out
beep it up we'll get beeped out
this why this is the voice of reason
right now i don't understand she's the
calming she's the
esther is calming me down right now so
we know something's up you're the energy
you're the battery pack and i'm the the
a bad battery pack no what is it like
upper and a downer
the upper and the downer the two ends of
the battery
no no no battery okay she's like
she's like adderall you're fantastic now
she's meth yeah sure
you're heroin you're you're like i like
that you tried to do it cute
and she was like no so you're the turn
down she's attorney okay i just like
it's very very hard to be mad about
[ __ ] traffic but it was and it was
too long it was too long one hour is
fine
over a [ __ ] hour is unacceptable it's
the price you pay for the world coming
up
i was infuriated i'm so mad i'm
and i don't think i need to say it but
i'm wearing a red shirt for a reason
okay
[Laughter]
i i'm probably about to pop my period so
bad that the the blood will squirt
upward
i'm scared to have anything white near
me i'm just like i felt the period rage
in me and i was like
not in this [ __ ] traffic [ __ ] i was
so upset you look so
cute in those really but i'm just saying
no i want to see your pretty eyes okay
is a predator
by the way we call her the grim groomer
and i don't know if we're ready to like
are we ready to announce this we said
that once at lunch at mendocino farms
what were you doing in that moment
tickling the back of my eyes
are you doing us there she took her life
up to her vagina her vagina region
and remember she's the one who got
turned on i was like whoa
you're like the groomer of the woman
because she speaks
did you guys you couldn't get in any of
the clubs if you were just hanging out
outside
chewing bubble gum while everyone was
smoking cigs
can we get him as a guest oh my god
you're two in the room together i
wouldn't be able to
prepare your bell i feel like she's
coming for you
i'm so not okay with this okay just so
you know the call bell was not my idea
it was my idea it was born out of the
voice of who i am
but it wasn't my idea a high-pitched
annoying sound
kalila yeah
kalila says that i get a call bell for
when i'm uncomfortable or when i need a
treat
or a potty break a potty break oh my god
i'm gonna let you
just have that
[Music]
um we missed you last night esther how
was it it was so fun
i should have brought you on stage would
you have been so embarrassed i'm
embarrassed
i'm so glad i was like oh my god where
are you sitting i didn't know where you
were sitting
back middle okay so we were at the i did
i headlined the bray improv sold out
keep please coming to the shows that my
ego is just
very fragile um but
uh kalila came with uh her sister and
her
brother your sister went wow jules went
the fam and i knew that if i said you're
in the audience like it would be like a
pouncing
like i would say just everyone turn and
start
did you say it no i didn't know you
could just secret but
then kalyla they didn't send her like
they should have taken you back to the
green room right away
yeah but kalila was just missing i was
like where's collapse and then i go like
she had she had a pee and then they
started taking pictures with her in the
bathroom dude oh my god do people like
catch you in the bathroom
oh wait i took so many bathroom pictures
but it was one of those like
that was just [ __ ] but then also with
some fans
it was cute because like you know that's
where that's where girls congregate yeah
we talk that's where we like touch each
other's boobs
it was very it's a it was a very cute
moment this show was a girl
i feel like we're very bathroom talk oh
my god are we bathroom girls
i think we are bathroom girls i think
that's our vibe
you guys are making me feel like i
really want to do a show the three of us
i know we have to like well we had to do
the play first of
all we opened with a play if we don't
write a [ __ ] play
but klyla will you do a live show i will
do a live show
as long as annie doesn't force me to do
any stand up which she has threatened
no this morning
it's like a live podcast if i have to
just stand up um i'm out
and for those reasons i'm out
i i can't i can't do it can we pitch our
podcast on shark tank
like can we get investors we want a
billboard really guys what we want is a
billboard
okay i don't know why but we have to
have one who do you think is gonna bite
of all of the the sharks well if i keep
getting a bell rung at me i will sue her
for discrimination i think that mark
cuban will bite
oh you mean those i mean no he's the
hardest shark to get i think
our cuban is somebody who listens to
here are the people who i think listen
to our show by the way
i secretly believe meghan markle listens
to our show what
why do you think that she went she's had
a lot of emotions
she went to immaculate heart down the
street i used to live i know that girl
she's an la girl
she is playing up the part of what she
needs to be but i know like
who she is in her core and she's a dirty
dirty [ __ ] like
well she's an actress like she's just a
hollywood actress originally like she's
she is like when she had to go i felt so
upset when she was
got married to the to prince harry
because why the prison because her
outfits got so bad immediately like she
was just like this hollywood
you know like becoming a celebrity like
killing it on her own
dressing and then also she had cowl
necks and like
quarter length sleeves it was like so
upsetting do you know the weirdest thing
about being in this business
is that you love cal next no is that
like
i amongst many other people i know her
ex-husband
he's a manager that's right and i
remember he like finding that out and
was just like
oh my god like it's did she manage her i
don't think so i don't know
was it like celine dion and renee no
when she was 14.
oh my god that is a sacred love don't
compare to that yeah
is that who you're you're mirroring
yourself after dave is
davis renee and i'm celine no but
you know creepy okay are you thinking
you're selling deanna can i
share this must be a dress that seems
creepy but isn't it
so you know how catherine mcphee is
dating david foster
yes and he's like yeah baby
and she's what like 38 and he's like 71.
seems random seems weird i have been
watching videos of them on youtube
together
singing and it is the cutest like i want
their relationship
it's so sweet it's so weird to say i
want someone's relationship
and worth noting
[Music]
it's like you're single worth noting he
broke up the band chicago
and he stole peter saterra and told him
to make a solo album so
david foster is not without fault he
also admitted that he told celine dion
david foster told celine dion that if
she recorded my heart will go on it
would ruin her career
why did he say it though i could see how
you'd be like oh maybe this is a cheesy
song like
he is a hit maker yeah definitely but i
think
he um i don't know how to say this
um but he is a is a homewrecker
really well like in music wise right
like
you you don't take the perfection that
chicago was which is like 17 man band
was in chicago like 17 members
and you pluck out one and you make like
80 ballots what's a chicago song that i
know you know
i know i don't really know my dad
listened to it but i can't think of a
song
do you are you a big fan i know she's
very
upset about it you'd be surprised a lot
of chicago another chicago-based thing i
love band i love is wilco
do your parents listen to wilco oh my
god no wilco is more dave
wilco is chicago well wilco is a chicago
band
wilco i know it's hard to say i'm sorry
you're the me oh i know that's you in my
life
you're the inspiration oh my god i know
what you're doing on our show
what am i doing singing we'll put like
one spotlight on you oh choose the
filipino no
that jean missed me just for the record
it missed the dance and mike
i missed that gene completely no no no
everything okay the crowd's going
if you leave me now you take me
we're at a 500 seat room okay it's
packed
okay everyone's getting red they're
they're restless you're not setting me
up
they're getting their glasses and
they're getting their last drinks and
finally the announcer goes
are you guys ready for the blank name
you guys ready for a lady
are you guys ready for some girls
do you love the podcast that was
formerly named bloodbath
and now they like scream and they do
waffles rule
and then um it's pitch black okay
we just hear a little bit of a pitter
patter and then
a spotlight david foster piano yes david
foster and piano yeah david foster on
the piano
then like connie chung no asian relation
kalyala has gotten wasted she's on top
of the
she's on top she's on top of the piano
and she just starts singing
oh no baby please don't go
oh my god the audience stands i like
screaming
esther comes out dancing i
i pull i pull one ted out then the other
than both
i mean your greatest talent
now how big of an issue is traffic gonna
be or is this just a red week situation
it was i think it's friday it's never
been isn't it worth it for being where
you get getting to be where you live
it is worth it ah no it's not i really
i've never been more angry in my life
the person making a left in front of me
like you know how like when you have to
make a left
and the it's green and you can't make
your left yet but you scoot into the
[ __ ] intersection
every human on earth scoots in the
[ __ ] inner section
i get behind this guy three lights he
just doesn't move
i don't know i'm like are you did you
die [ __ ] i'm trying to get a cpr
i'm like on the [ __ ] horn then he
just goes i'm like the cars are coming
you can't just go
so then they all halted i'm like
psychopath like it's like the first day
driving i was so [ __ ] mad
wait do you have do you normally have
road rage
are you like i made a choice in my life
to not have road rage what kind of
driver are you
i'm one that sits in a [ __ ] passenger
seat
i get driven i feel like that's all of
no but i like to i drive myself i don't
have a driver
wait esther gets in the car by the way
her little head is this far over the you
just see her
she's this big you just see the little
tip of her head and she drives up her
hands are up here
i'm such a real follower i drive like a
grandma i do too
i i never like i'm always on the three
most right lanes on the freeway
i'm never cutting anyone out i am i
drive like
esther's grandmother when esther says
she's coming over
[Laughter]
i'm so excited about your going to your
grandmother's house yeah
will you give us a play-by-play for sure
yeah i'm really nervous about i haven't
seen her in you know
two three years did she invite you or no
no she didn't you're the first like
living person to like
haunt someone's house
[Laughter]
i was like are you gonna honk the horn
and say grandma i might be seeing you
today
my mom has told her so i'm going with my
mom and my sister
has buffers yeah i'm definitely the
least favorite
um but you know she has her reasons for
disliking everybody i mean you are
annoying but you are lovable i can't
believe this
it's just different i don't know what
it's just like
a culture i think you steal her grandma
energy that's what it is
no i think it's i'm so much like my dad
and like you have to remember that side
of the family is like
quite trash and like i'm jewish
and so i think it's i just feel that
that's at play in some way
i don't know but i know i don't know
your grandmother didn't post stop
anti-semitism
do you guys want to see my banged up
knee yeah
oh i don't want to even look you see it
i love it wait let me look
no you're going to poke it aren't you
oh master rang the bell she's nothing
like bruises
i can't hear bells i forgot to tell you
guys
i'm like a dog i can only hear her
whistle how did you get that
bruise um basically
sucking nature's dick i want to say this
but
i know we can't i can't say it i don't
know what to say
it's like a bad word but it's my
favorite word that annie uses we'll just
bleep it out but i was being
i was hiking i was in nature it was very
rainy
it was very um torrential rain and i
insisted on taking the
an off the beaten path hike and i paid
the price always do
yeah you guys were soaking wet in the
pictures was it just like it was mud up
to our knees
and my friend was like wait a second
this is a really bad time bad day to
hike this particular hike i'm a local
trust me i was like i'm not afraid of
mud turns out like all i dream about the
last five days is mud
like i drift off into sleep and i wake
up thinking that i'm back there
you know like knee deep in mine you know
what i like about this this is like so
you're
like i can't like i'll never back down
from a challenge yeah like they're local
saying we don't want to go in the mud
and you're like yeah you didn't want to
know i'll go and they're like [ __ ] we
don't want to go we're telling we don't
want to go
and you're like i will not back down and
like just had to follow you
yeah it was a mistake but um i learned
my lesson and i am humbled by nature
and i will not be doing that hike again
but you did survive
so it's not like a kill like i would be
scared that if they said that that like
you'd go and then you would die
well esther you would be it would be
like to your eyebrows
even crossing the rivers faster you
wouldn't have made it it would have come
out here
i posted a picture of um me and kalila
from the show and people were like
is esther there but she's just too short
to be it's so weird i'm not even that
short
like i don't get it you are that short i
really don't like no one brings up my
height ever
ever that because you're so short they
don't want to be rude
oh my god that's not true that's true
i'm five
foot almost one that means she's five
nine guys do you understand that right
five nine five eleven sorry
you mean four four eleven no i'm not i'm
not going to math all right
she doesn't know the number she's as
short as the boss i wrote to math class
okay and he doesn't know the us number
system
you're on the metric system the rest of
the world operates on that you're fine
i thought it was the us number system oh
no
did you ever get caught calling us
weekly us weekly yeah all the time
oh isn't that oh george
we don't expect that from you and by the
way when i realized
what happens to me when i'm pmsing is i
just i have that moment where i'm like
upset i'm like i don't know who to blame
and then i'm like it's men
because i get so like [ __ ] you guys you
don't [ __ ] have to do this [ __ ]
you your blessed existence it's [ __ ]
annoying
and i that is why i make sure i bleed
all over the beds of every man i
spend time with are you gonna uh have
sex on your period type of gap yeah
that's the only time i've already talked
about oh yeah we make our special sauce
a special sauce oh god i know it's gross
nobody's ever liked it by the way when i
said the special thing never once
it's never gone over well what do they
call that
um strawberry shortcake
that sounds like thousand island
mayonnaise and ketchup no
yes thousand islands better than
strawberries but that's got relish and
yeah boogers my boogers are very flaky
and hard and bloody mine are yeah mine
are
california those are called california
boogers thank you for validating
chaparral boogers we live in a chaperone
what's a chaperone california it's like
kind of almost a desert but not quite
there are just like words that i would
never hear if i didn't know you
it's fifth grade
ladies if you're looking for the perfect
gift to give to the men in your life
manscaped has you covered it's father's
day which means you have the opportunity
to give the best gifts of all
the brand new the brand new lawnmower
4.0 body trimmer and ultra smooth
package
also honestly for your dad my dad has
like ear hair and nose hair and [ __ ]
they have the good
nose but specifically the lawnmower 4.0
trimmer is now available in the usa and
canada
the optimized lawnmower 4.0 trimmer is
waterproof so your man can groom in the
shower and not have to worry about
cleaning up a mess on the bathroom floor
it also includes a new multi-function on
off switch
that can engage a travel lock and it's
created for men on the go and gives you
the ability to turn
the 4000k led spotlight on and off when
needed for a more precise
shave the manscaped ultra smooth package
consists of the razor and a set for men
to get trimmed front to back so ladies
you can finally have your razor back
they no longer have to secretly borrow
yours for a precise trim here are the
steps
step one crop exfoliator infused with
ingredients that can soothe clear and
keep the skin on and around your groin
feeling refreshed
step two crop gel step three it's time
to shave
the crop shaver is not your average
razor it's smaller thicker with a micro
comb bar that allows for the best shave
possible from any angle
ladies this is the perfect gift for the
men in your life and men
your aunties will thank you get 20
off plus free shipping with a code
bloodbath at manscape.com that's 20
off and free shipping with a code
bloodbath at manscape.com
it's a dad bod season guys time to get
smooth
do it for your dad he did a lot for you
let's talk about blue chew
okay we love blue chew here blue chew is
a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost
you can take them anytime day or night
so you can plan ahead
really important for the planner types
for the morning wood you say or you can
be ready you can be ready whenever the
opportunity arises the process is simple
sign up at bluechew.com consult with one
of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days
the best part it's all done online so no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discrete package
big plus guys there's nothing sexier
than confidence and blue chew can help
give you confidence where it counts
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
bluetooth can help and we've got a
special deal for our listeners try
bluetooth free
when you use our promo code bathgirls at
checkout you just pay five dollar
shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code bathgirls
to receive your first month free
visit bluechew.com for more details and
important safety information
ladies blue chew is exclusively for men
but the end result is something
you'll both enjoy so get your man to
sign up
up
guys i listen i got i skipped eighth
grade for no reason
um you went from first to eighth i went
i went
i i went to seventh grade i repeated
kindergarten
i wasn't kidding no you were yes i was
did your brother
too yeah well the reason they held his
back was because he had learning
disabilities and they didn't discover
mine until they tried to
get me to read and then they're like oh
glad we held them both back
because they had they had a choice to
let me go forward but i mean that would
have been so embarrassing oh that's
sweet so they held us both back and by
the way max maybe you never heard this
they told me never to tell you also mom
killed the rat
your rat rascal did not die of natural
causes mom put a bag over him and then a
book on top
are you [ __ ] kidding but she had to
because he was like
[Music]
but and also she found all the hard
socks under her bed she didn't want me
to tell you but anyway
max i hope your career is doing great
and i love you
i have a question yeah do you have
period sex
yeah i i take it to the next level what
do you mean
um i do this in your mouth where no like
i have
i have my partner pull out the tampon
and everything
what with their teeth it's part of the
it's part of the kink
why can you teach us i just want him to
um the champagne know this for
i myself i want to pop the bottle i went
to a really nice restaurant like
fancy-ass restaurant with todd
and he ordered duck and they brought it
with like a
um glass case over it and it was all
steaming and then they lifted the case
up
and they push all the smoke into his
face like when you pull the tampon it's
like all the stench
goes right into his face like i wanted
to have the whole experience so can you
explain why
like what what explain the like the
narrative there like what is
because it's kind of like the time of
month where like
it's naughty it's yeah it's naughtier
because you're like oh it's
messier it's just like not ideal right
so i like to go from beginning to end i
don't want to serve the dish
like i want him to work for the dish you
know what i mean
so just pull it out and then yeah if you
have a kid are you gonna make are you
gonna like have it in a tub and have
bobby deliver it
not a chance i'm getting full blast
epidural [ __ ] that all then
the only reason i ask is because she
said she wants him to be part of the
experience from the beginning to the end
so i was thinking the end of the tampon
you know is delivering a baby
i don't think i could ever do um a home
birth um
only because it's i'm already afraid
of like weird health so i'm like
but my dad used to say he's like just do
it old school just like hug a tree and
push it out
what really there are videos and my dad
went to he went to med school he was
never practicing doctor but he went to
med school
in as an ob gyn gynecologist
are you serious so he helped deliver my
sister and i he did
everything in the philippines yeah and
in mexico too what does this hug a tree
does that like you squish the baby on
the tree
yeah just hug a tree don't squish the
baby and it's just something to hold on
to
hug a tree and push it out do you
when when donut won't [ __ ] do you just
squeeze it
why else hug a tree this stomach i think
it's like so you're like holding
something so you're not like
and then you get because it felt like
over here like the idea is that you're
on your back
your legs are open and you give birth
right it's i watch
the business of being born it's a
documentary by ricky lake
about uh home births i watched it like
with four friends that were pregnant
and so it's all these home births you
see ricky like like naked in a [ __ ]
tub popping a baby out and then
she has this really [ __ ] gangster-ass
midwife who is from um or i think she's
a midwife i don't know the difference
between a duel and a midwife but
midwives from births the doula is too
it's almost
yeah she's like licensed to birth a baby
she was just like this brooklyn [ __ ]
like she was just so cool
and i remembered her and she gives birth
in it too and she was saying how she
like
had like a really really hard home birth
and it helped her with the other
births or whatever but so then she comes
into my restaurant
ricky lake no the doula abdullah it was
like
so cool so then she comes in my
restaurant and i'm like do you say like
i've seen your vagina as wide as it
possibly can be like do i say like
hey [ __ ] i seen it
big fan i was like star struck but i
didn't say anything because i didn't
want to
embarrass her that i'd seen her the jazz
hole i thought
ricky lake gave birth no it's a lot of
people giving birth but she also so the
woman it was
ricky lake was just like presenting
the thesis that you can give birth at
home and that maybe it's not the best
idea to go to the hospital so they were
the whole movie was like was
you saw a lot of births i have to say i
really wonder what kind of person
like what brings people to want that
line of work
where you're delivering babies whether
it's midwife or the doctor
i i don't i know it's just like i have a
weird aversion to
that like it just seems scary to me i
wonder like
do people get like oh i'm actually
bringing life into the world do they get
that out of it
yes you think even yeah because even i
didn't think that i
particularly cared about births at all
until i did like my l d rotation for
nursing school
and it really is emotional and even if
you don't know those strangers it just
is so the room is like it's like a you
can feel
the it's it's a really emotional thing
and
i don't think like i think for them
probably it starts to become routine
but i think it's special every time
there is something special about it
every time and to see people in those
extremes of like pain and then like the
joy of their baby being born god i mean
i know they're the only ones that know
what we're talking about
but they're men and we don't give a [ __ ]
what they have to say
and they're white like my favorite show
is this
oh double i didn't have to say that
and there were and he's a [ __ ] weird
blonde ginger that's like
what's even happening there evil evil
jor you don't think george is evil
there's a darkness in that man look at
him
he does coke he is
that's how he gets all our clips done
he's a [ __ ] cokehead he's doing lines
rails
turn up turn down he does both of you
fentanyl and meth
someone tried to give me coke last night
at the show oh really what
yeah it was girl what is that it was a
boy
um he had a shirt with mushrooms on it i
was like i thought you were into
something different
um but he yeah he was like take the and
i was like what is that i would
never like someone did give me a
chocolate bar of mushrooms like of
mushroom chocolate which i was like that
is so sweet
one time at one on my show someone gave
me a strawberry rhubarb pie
i wish i drugged it i wish there was
something in it there wasn't it was
delicious it's my favorite flavor pie
that's sweet why rhubarb i know i keep
every time i look at your
your stories you're always doing
something with rhubarb why rhubarb
i think it's so it it's a tart
if you just bite into a stick a stalk of
rhubarb you get this like
tart almost like sour patch kid tartness
like not obviously a sugary but um and
so then when you mix that
with strawberries come on now
you should be a doula this is exactly
the experience this is this is no this
is the passion a doula needs
you know what else rhubarb does it empty
does it [ __ ] on the table
in front of everyone it makes you [ __ ]
on the table
really yeah it has so much like i'm not
sure if it gives you some
if it has a lot of fiber but that [ __ ]
cleans me out i tried planting it this
year but it didn't work so
oh i've seen your plans okay so i
started gardening
last year in kovid and
like every so often you i would go out
and prune because that's i
didn't know this but the more you prune
for certain plants the more growth so
i'm like really into pruning my mint
um her fingers and toes in the tub
that too every night um so anyways i
would go outside and i would prune
my mint and i'd prune the tomato plants
i'd just prune all these plants like all
a lot
really often and then
like then one time when i did it
dave came outside and he's like
where do you think all those leaves go
when you just leave them
all over like the floor outside and i'm
like oh my god it's actually really cool
so it's really cool because you do this
and then the birds
come and get it and like the birds love
it so it's like it works perfectly
and he's like no it's not i've been
doing it
and then he flew away that was the twist
he is actually half her that is the
weird part
so now like all the time dave dave will
wrote he'll be like
oh are the birds gonna do that for you
it's just so funny how cocky or that you
thought you were teaching i know i was
like actually
the miracle of life is beautiful i think
it's really cute you thought you were in
a cinderella type of film mary poppins
when you have rats as friends and birds
as helpers
she's got pigs as friends we do have
lizards and
a slug last night in our garden i saw
the picture you tagged us
yeah i love that slug i know he hasn't
found his home yet clearly
yeah wait why does he have a shell he
will eventually he'll make some calcium
carbonate for it
okay of course she knows how it happens
that's about shells but that's the
coolest thing to me about living in la
is seeing little lizards in my yard
that's just although one time there was
one in the house and that was
that got ugly but that's the coolest way
living in l.a you want
to be walking by olivia wilde's house
which is getting in the car that was my
favorite part about
living in l.a i was like oh my god it's
olivia wilde
no there's annie come on look at the
slugs
what's his name that's that's that one
guy i see everywhere in l.a um the guy
from forgetting sarah marshall
jason oh jason i see him
i swear to you like once a week well
he's like six
eight or something crazy right right but
he's always crossing the road without a
crosswalk and i'm always thinking to
myself like does god
want us to meet but it's just not
happening
or does god seem like i swear to you
guys like 25 times in l.a
or does he want people to see him a lot
in traffic where he's like i'll just if
i jaywalk they'll notice
or am i
just plotting my days around him uh you
guys have you guys seen um
the headlines is it are they even
headlines about um the thrupal or what
do you call
what do you call a couple with four
people a quad
quadruple quadruple i don't know i'm
really bad at us math so
metric system only why what's going on
so you guys know who tycho ytt is he's
like a big director
right he's done my favorite movie of all
boy jojo rabbit boy yeah it's one of his
early ones it's like one of my favorite
was he did
the hunt for the wilder people i didn't
know he saw her show
[Laughter]
highly recommend boy is one of the best
films i've ever seen in my life it's so
cute
but he was caught there was a picture of
him
with tessa thompson and um what's her
name um
rita ora and tessa thompson is the one
that's from she's in
she's in a lot of things she's in a lot
of things yeah she's in west world right
yeah but they were basically doing like
a triple kiss
and um i don't know i i just wanted to
know what you guys think of
but why are there four oh and then
randomly there was a picture like she
made out with another guys people are
thinking that this hot model guy is also
part of their quad
listen i was a waitress at this place
called the cowgirl
and they used to give us a staff party
during super bowl they would shut the
place down
yeah and let's just say i wasn't in a
quadruple i was in a
what's a 15 person oh an orgy
they gave us free alcohol so we would
just get wasted and give us free food
and watch the super bowl and what would
you do that makes this
is there's so many pictures of me tongue
kissing like a bus boy a manager
that makes one of the other way orgies
makes sense if i don't really know who
i'm having an orgy with i would never do
if like if i was an a-lister like any of
these three i would never
have an a-list orgy i would go straight
down
i think they probably are having a it's
probably a relationship between five of
them
and the other person is what we call
molly
it seems a little druggy but was this
all like this was just one time right
yeah these are just assumptions i just
was really excited about it because it's
like it's so
because you've lived in a relationship
with two men
yes so she's like i've been one up this
is like right up your alley
this is right up my ass you're the
professional here what do you really
think
i'm a trailblazer what do you think is
going on
um i think that there's a whole lot of
fun exhausting sex happening
just rich people just on vacations just
oh
this is gonna be us season two this is
weird it's really hard for me to think
of like
famous people like those people are like
all having sex together i don't know why
but but also like those are always the
kind of people that party the hardest
anyways i'm like delusional about that
but that would be crazy
it's a fun hollywood rumor i feel like
because the internet like
oversaturated everyone you don't hear
these goods like remember the story
remember
when um there was the rumor that benicio
del toro banged scarlett johansson in
the
in an elevator no yeah i mean i don't i
can't confirm it
it was me pretending to be here
that's exciting but isn't that a fun one
yeah but i agree
with like kind of annie's point i think
that that sounds
like three people haven't or four people
just having a real
fun night getting off to the craziness
of a triple kiss
that's what's going to happen after you
my special rhubarb
is that our new podcast name triple cash
okay i think i tried that several times
actually in the beginning i was like
triple kiss and you guys were like
you're trash get out of your [ __ ] i'm
like
it was also coveted back then even
better
let's we don't give a [ __ ]
i'm excited about it i think that guy's
hot he's really cute what is it where is
he from
taika yeah he is really hot he's so hot
he's so hot
but he's also so funny he's so funny
that's what makes him sort of like my
dream guy but how do you know that about
him
because all of his movies that he's been
in like his earlier movies like even boy
he is in and he's so good like he's a
triple threat like he does everything
he's so talented how old is he because
he has gray hair but he has
little man 44. oh really he looks like
he could be one of those people it's
like 32 with gray hair yeah but he's
from new zealand
he's got a nice hand skin he's got like
the the silver fox
new zealand moment do you remember my
new zealand moment from new zealand
i want to hear new zealand moment i
gotta find the picture
oh my god i feel bad i own new zealand
moment but i wasn't a guy i just went
there
you had tonsillitis in new zealand and
you cured me
i did i didn't cure you i said esther go
ask for a prescription for augmentin
that doesn't care yeah she sent me that
she sent me to urgent care in new
zealand
dave was so mad at me for being why yeah
this is the problem with when you're
annoying when you're not sick i know
don't get any sick treatment
i know remember that next time you're
having a good day i just have to cherish
the first like six months of our
uh relationship when i'd be like this
hurts you'd be like what
are you okay and then the seventh month
when you're like move in with me or it's
done
like that's when i came and drove i was
like oh my god i always was like esther
this is not gonna work and it always
worked it's crazy
poor dave when bobby and i first started
dating he was lucky
i didn't know that he was just a
dramatic guy and he would always say
things like oh i had such a bad son i'm
gonna go kill myself and i believed him
i truly thought like you know he had
like a collapse of mental health and
like let me call the doctor that
molested me when i was gonna kill myself
but now all that even today i'm so
lonely babe i'm gonna kill myself yeah
yeah
all right i don't give a [ __ ] anymore
just do it
well i okay so i would always say like
i'm just going to kill myself you just
like can't say that because no
so my friends i'm laughing into the
story
she does have a sense of humor her dad
offed himself
okay he had parkinson's off himself then
her aunt did
or her uncle did and then her aunt did
so whenever i'm like i'm gonna come i'm
like i promise i'm not gonna kill myself
like i promise
she's like please do not kill yourself
i'm like i promise it could be you
though it's becoming curse-like at this
point
me no her oh god no i'm over i
will never kill myself no way no the
earth will get me but it won't be
from my own hands everything gets better
you like live long enough where you're
like it really is like it gets better
it doesn't it just [ __ ] always gets
better if i had some insight
or even some like future seeing into
what my life would be god that really
could have saved me
i was just so sure i had nothing left in
store to like live for
i was so sure i was 150 sure
i was like this is just done i'm out but
now i wish there was just something to
see like look this what it might be
later on
and i would have been like oh okay you
know i know and your parents can't tell
you because you like hate them
you're like they're like it'll get
better like shut up [ __ ] you don't know
anything about me yeah it might not get
better but
it can get better yeah and so even that
option is very soothing but even if you
just like choose to make a bet you can
make your life better if you
choose to like look at life as like fun
i'm in traffic isn't that great some
people really are in like
the pit of depression you need help
it doesn't matter how much no i'm not
saying you don't need help but i'm just
saying you can always like turn your
life around you really can hopefully
with meds and proper like care and all
of that
hopefully yes
okay fun fact most home remedies and
over-the-counter acne products
don't work and they can even make things
worse and damage your skin
that's why we're excited to partner with
apostrophe a sponsor of this episode
i've done some crazy things to help my
skin and
the craziest one was i used hemorrhoid
cream unfortunately it had already been
used by my ex-boyfriend
i'm just saying because of apostrophe i
no longer have to do that i will never
have pinkeye again
apostrophe is a prescription skincare
company that offers science-backed oral
and topical medications that are
clinically proven to help clear acne
apostrophe connects you with a
board-certified dermatologist who will
create a personalized treatment plan
that is perfectly tailored
to your unique skin simply fill out
apostrophe's online quiz about your skin
goals
and medical history then you snap a few
selfies and your dermatologist will
create your customized treatment plan
apostrophe treats acne they can also
help you hit your skin care goals like
reducing redness wrinkles and even dark
spots which is my problem i have a lot
of like little melasma
spots from over sun exposure i have no
redness
we have a special deal for our audience
today save 15
off your first visit with a
board-certified dermatologist at
apostrophe.com
bathgirls when you use our code
bathgirls this code is only available to
our listeners by the way so get on it
guys
to get started just go to apostrophe.com
bathgirls and click begin visit then use
our code bathgirls at sign up and you'll
get 15
off your dermatology visit that's
a-p-o-s-t-r-o-p-h-e
dot com slash bathgirls and use that
code bathgirls to get your dermatology
visit and save 15
thank you apostrophe for sponsoring this
podcast
um bobby's in hungary and he is hanging
out with
my number one crush of all time and i
cannot
bear it he knows for a fact that my
number one i've talked about on tiger
belly for years my number one on my list
is edgar ramirez and bobby just sent me
a picture of him working with him and i
just
i did an internal scream is he truly
your hall pass
he is my absolute number one hall pass
oh
oh yeah i know that guy what's he in
he was he played choco in um with kira
knightley that's where i
first had a question which means he's
five sex
oh he's hot that's not olivia the
picture of him
right with the blue background
that one is very hot that's he was just
in that movie with or the tv show
undoing the undoing it was down
done and he was also he played roberto
duran in
manos de piedras our hall pass is real
like no one really has that right
um i guess it depends what arrangement
you have with your partner
because i had three okay i had three
guys
who were like my favorite
guys right like for like a decade
or more i was like these are my three
guys like
they're so hot i [ __ ] love them i
literally
met well i met two of them one of them i
didn't meet but
i by meeting two of them
i completely like was like what am i no
i was like what was this was the like i
don't know i just
i almost feel like the concept of a hall
pass after meeting
the ones that i thought were mine and it
just being so
normal there's nothing more annoying
than the fact that you're not going to
say their names
i know i need to hear a message i can't
but what a life right
what a life we live that we can come
inches away from our actual hall passes
because most people who have hall passes
never come that close yeah i know when
you live in hollywood you're saying that
you're pretty much
hey can i [ __ ] this guy one time at a
party that's good
do you mind if i bang this guy but i
will i believe now
i feel like i've been so naive but
literally that [ __ ] happens in holiday
waters
yes well i asked my agent when because i
had prayed for i had such a crush on um
leave schreiber and i was like i had
prayed i was like i want him and naomi
to break up like i'm looking
i want to be like a good breakup and
there's no issue and the kids are happy
and then i'm coming in on it so they
break up i had my google alerts ready
they break up it's a good breakup as far
as we know i call my agent i go
get me to a ray donovan party i will do
the rest
he laughed i was like i've never been
more serious in this
life he did not get it done and then i'm
glad because then
i just like i don't care anymore i have
no interest in it
i have a lot of interest in it i don't
know
i feel like we're trying to tell you
that this is not what you think it is
they're just
once you meet them they're horrible no
because bobby confirmed he was like i
know why he's your hall pass i get it
he is so good looking kalila oh my god
he does look like someone that's way
better looking
but then too yeah and i told bobby i was
like well let me fly me out there he's
like absolutely not
but here's the thing when guys are hot
like that and i feel them like
working me i get turned off so do i i
really hate that but that's why i like
him so i watch all of his interviews
right
yeah and he just doesn't seem like that
type of
like hollywood weasel he's from
venezuela he's like uh you know
he's got an accent he's got it all done
cuts
we're pro uncut here if you're cut put
the skin back on
be one of those guys that gets a cinder
block and hangs it off do you know that
there's like a hole there's like a hole
i was like i'm still jewish guys please
stop
do not take out all my men
filipinos too filipinos are the jewish
people of asia all
circumcised i all of my friends that are
having kids are not circumcised and if
you're not they call you pistol then
you're like humiliated as a child
dave is really against it dave is like
it's off the table
it would be off the table for me too
yeah really why for you
i just think that like i grew up in a
country where like they they had all
these like myths around it
and it's it just um i want them to make
that decision when they're a little bit
older
i can't cut your dick for you also i had
a friend who got circumcised
as a kid and they took a little bit too
much out so when he gets a full boner
it it uh it stretches
his head skin and it hurts him a lot oh
my god oh that sucks i've definitely had
boyfriends that have had much
circumstances what yeah i had a
boyfriend
[ __ ] marky had a uh what does that name
mean
she's mexican he named himself but he
i'm sorry i cannot
not honor his wishes but he had um
a botched circumcision so i used to say
he had a mock turtleneck
like you got to fix it he had a cowl
neck he got it fixed when he was
looking meghan markle in there he
literally
he had to get a re-circumcision at 30.
at 30. so funny what about you esther
like would you be circumcised if you
ever had a child
would you just be like all right well i
don't have a strong feeling
because it seems like there's such
conflicting informational out there
about it
i um i think i would just let
follow dave's lead um maybe do a little
research
but i don't know we live in america so
like we love
uncuts is okay here if i were to raise a
child in the philippines i think i would
feel pressured to
glom co-clamp that do you know what it
reminds me of
it reminds me of how
being like paris hilton's body was like
the number one body like the runway
model's bodies were in everyone's bodies
back in the day
and then you got [ __ ] on if you had big
ass and big tits yeah well maybe not big
tits but
big ass and then now it's flipped it's
like everyone gets their day so like
uncircumcised dicks are gonna be like
making fun of circumcised dicks in the
shower well it's like just whoever you
are just hold out
yeah eventually it'll come in style
you're gonna have your moment that is so
weird my mom told me that in high school
people called her bubble butt and like
made fun of her and like she was
humiliated and it was embarrassing i'm
like
juliana cried her whole childhood
because she had
really big lips oh my gosh you see how
big and
beautiful her lips are and um she was
teased for having just really really big
lips and i
used to tell her when she was young hold
out like this is a good thing
you're like i can't tell you what dsl
means but you got them yeah yeah
i got them hot commodity
wait what if your boyfriend had a hall
pass i'd be like
ew like if one of my boyfriend's like i
have a haul i'd be like i'm your [ __ ]
hall pass
i've never like todd taught i've had a
couple hot boyfriends but
for the most part i'm like you got to be
kidding me first of all
you're as big as the hall let's be real
i dated some big boys
but i'm like your hall pass [ __ ] you i
wonder bobby has never talked to me
about
like a hall pass ever i'm as good as
he'll ever be yeah
so i think so well not really because he
has dated really hot hot girls in the
past
yeah but that was before
well i guess he's getting richer maybe
is it time for a banana break
i think so
oh i will eat a banana if you retract
the way you just pronounced it i like to
picture banana break like we all put
sunglasses on and we're rubbing suntan
lotion on each other
you are a lesbian
i just want to let you know this is a
great banana i congratulate you
oh thank you so much look we're
circumcising the banana
bananas come circumcised oh my god
are they washed oh my god pee is um
todd um allowed to ogle is that the word
ogle
google goggle we all
don't know oogle ogle banana
oh my god annie
annie the bell is is void
every banana breaks does todd ogle or
say that woman is hot around you
he would no about like a celebrity and
the same to you esther
when you're together for 10 years which
i think you have been to
it's like who cares i talk openly about
who's hot i let him talk openly about
who's house well i'm sure he doesn't
care when you're talking only about
women
oh no that actually bothers him i know
because it's real
am i your hall pass
[Laughter]
how cocky would that be if i thought i
was your fault
that is a funny like strategy to go up
to somebody like i know i'm your hall
past you [ __ ]
or go up to someone and say that you're
there yours that's really creepy
oh i've had that happen to me oh i just
remembered i was doing an interview i'm
not saying anything else but the
interviewer was like
i forgot what he said was something like
if i had a hall pass
larry king no oh my god but larry is
lord
you know we had chemistry you guys had
definite chemistry you know that he went
off script
asked me if i had a boyfriend that's why
i said larry king
i me and larry king would have had the
relationship of a lifetime
we would have listened to sammy davis jr
he would have talked to me about me and
nicole smith well if you hadn't gone
their mask list and [ __ ]
taken him out guys i made a little p
hole for it
larry king dick opera it's esther safety
i'm giving it veins i'm giving it veins
when's your birthday oh my god
guys well you're really nervous you
don't make a left-hand turn when you're
supposed to
[Laughter]
you know who i thought i was for sure
not going to find attractive because he
did such a good job
in that one show with nicole kidman um
reese witherspoon little
bit big little lies ella's alexander
skarsgard
oh he is so hot though he's so hot so i
was like oh but he was such an abuser in
the show i was like i
hated him i hate him on the show and
then i saw him jules and i saw him
having coffee
and then not only that but was so
attractive is that he
he's actually an esther he goes into the
most
[ __ ] up looking 1991 box of a car
and he's like really tall i thought
you're going to say he like refused to
eat any of the food
and like i just thought i was like oh my
god like he couldn't be hotter to me
right now the fact that he
was fine drove away in some [ __ ]
successful man in a shitty car
hot is so hot dude but because he's so
hot he can't he knows like we're not
gonna
like he's too hot to [ __ ] like he really
is
yeah you have to have something wrong i
don't go for hot guys this is like not
i saw him at a party it's a losing game
i saw at a party i was on
i was dating this guy like on and off
his friend was so sure we weren't dating
because we were not a physical match
that he kept going
you should go try to get alexander
skarsgard's number and stuff i'm like
you're gonna make this little man
feel so bad like i get no clue i was
dating this guy
i was like that one i was like but i'm
with this one
this one's like shake he's like
twitching you know my second on the list
of um hall passes which i feel like i'm
inching
closer and closer to is the actor from
in the mood for love
tony liang i did he's older now but oh
this is interesting i like learning more
so he's an older guy now but if you guys
watch in the mood for love
god go down and he's not sold yeah
no he i can be he doesn't look tall i'm
not
oh he's hot there he's hot there he's
still
hot but he when you when you see him
there's an essence about him
are you ever attracted to white men yeah
alexander
scott yeah um i
i find asian man super super attractive
so i think that i have a natural like
tug in that direction yeah but i've
dated all i
accept that my dream
to actually date and not just like make
out with is like a
an indian an indian guy
from these the east coast not in l.a
but from the east coast the indian guys
are so hot for some reason i know what
you mean annie do you not
i'm just trying to think of one you only
have a caution in your head right
it's literally all i can think of as
akash which no offense
but you're like akash is um andrew
um i told a story on stage last night
about oh
i couldn't say his name right when i was
bringing him up i was like oh gosh
gosh oh gosh i was the host and then i
told a story about [ __ ]
and the word [ __ ] knocked the word
akash out of my head
and then i was like uh and i had to
bring him up so i just went
um please uh give a warm welcome to
mr singh and he was like 20. i caught a
mister saying and he had to come up and
just like
do a set about like mister
like his sneakers or whatever the [ __ ]
is that was about that back then you
know what i mean it was just like
so is there anything funnier than when
people [ __ ] each other's names up though
like when
when john travolta said remember when um
adele nazim
i know just made up like with um um
what's her name edina i don't even know
her real name
yeah well she's a cartoon character
sorry i just i know your voice
she's the original voice and the musical
wicked she
i believe she won the tony she's amazing
she married to tay diggs
she's she was right and nina menzel i
just know her as adele dizzy you didn't
know her name
i said her name idina menzel yes i did
oh my god
idina menzel from broadway's wicked are
you kidding me
i never saw wicked oh you gotta listen
to soundtracks
he was so sure when he freestyled her
name there was confidence in his voice
i was like it was supposed to be in high
school though
it's never gonna bring me down
i was like literally throwing tomato
value
we spoke weed we're cool [ __ ] you
everyone i was
bullied is so successful i'm like oh
[ __ ]
they've never lived in their cars that's
what my dad always said he said nerds
they're they rule the world i was like
all right dad
be a nerd and he said
guys make passes at girls who wear
glasses he was really like pushing me
into the like nerdy direction
and no joke one day at the dinner table
my dad sat me and my sister down
and he was like i would like you both to
seriously consider lesbianism
we're like what you're like dad i
already have
i know it was a in his head it was like
a funny bit that he was just gonna like
go and tell his friends he said that but
[Laughter]
if your dad had been like a little bit
younger when tick tock came out
then not 78. your dad by the way and her
mom looks so hot in sleepover by esther
it's weird they look hot they're like a
hot couple
that's so is that your dream um
those are my hall passes
wait so i heard we have questions today
what's up kelila annie and esther
my question for you ladies is if any of
you have struggled with social anxiety
and if so
what you do to overcome that love the
show
thanks for your response i'm going to
start because
i know that these girls are stage
performers so they've already overcome
that
i'm somebody that believes there's no
overcoming it you just live through it
you just tell people you sweat you tell
him you get a sweat mustache you tell
him you're awkward you tell him you
can't shake your hand
and you just [ __ ] own it yeah you
don't pretend to be something you're not
right and you just like oh my god i'm
sorry i'm nervous i'm weird
you know yeah i say like lean into it
yeah and don't even apologize for it
anymore it's just like
there's no one you can be but yourself
and you can never be better than
like just bettering yourself and just
being but if it's to soothe
yourself out of a panic attack which i
have to do often
because i have panic disorder um i do
this thing where you do like
panic at the door you cross your arms
like this and you
tap this way it's but you can
tell again you're a native american by
the minute it's wild she's like oh
whoa like and all of a sudden starts
raining out
but that's happening as soon as your um
your nervous system
oh i like that do you ever do tapping
this tapping i don't do i
anything where you alternate um sensory
stuff
really helps so if you don't like
tapping you can do the alternate
squeezing or
you hear audio with like binaural beats
so it goes boom on the right then boom
on the left
one time in therapy or so few times she
would have me hold these like little
buzzers
and then like it would just buzz
alternatively right
same thing same concept i also think for
social anxiety
um it's very normal and also like i
think you can never go wrong with just
dipping your toe in being quiet like i
never
it never bothers me when someone at the
event or the party is just kind of quiet
and enjoying themselves quietly
i don't think there's anything wrong
with that yeah i don't really get it i
just don't it's like not my business if
people don't like me so
if i'm happy with what i'm doing and i
stay aligned with what like i think is
cool
and what i want to do then i don't
really care about the thing around me
yeah and just know that like like you
i am very exhausted after social
interactions
i put on a very i've learned to fake it
till i make it
but when i go home it is i i need to
take a shower yeah
do a lot of steps to quiet decompress
you know like
wiggle my toes i do this thing called
noodling or like i just imagine i'm a
noodle
and you kind of like soften your your
body internally
i got noodles in college with a pool
noodle
i like that noodling yeah noodling where
it's like you imagine
like from the top of your head to the
tip of your toes right you sit
and just imagine that now you're a soft
noodle so you kind of like
relax into yourself are we doing uh just
gonna go right into the
um ads for blue chew
um what other questions do we have hi
bloodbath ladies
my name is killian uh i was just curious
what is one thing each of you would like
to do before you die
oh my god why are their voices all so
cute i know and sweet
and nice killian's a great name killian
murphy another one of my hall passes oh
my god we're killing it today
what is our answer to this question
just too many things that i want to do i
have like none
i want to write a book i want to write a
book i have
literally none like i've never been a
big bucket lister
you know go to the movies of popcorn i
know when do we get to
that's the bucket that's our pocket
bucket of popcorn
how much popcorn do you eat a lot and
we've talked about this on this show
already i don't share
the bucket do you get a refill yes
butter
popcorn i just go straight
no butter do you get a salad afterwards
to try to make it better
if i if i need to i don't know like it
would be cool to
learn how to cook
um it would be cool to like feel really
relaxed one time
my bucket list is for you to learn how
to cook too because
those pastries i'll never forget she
really puts the paste in pastries i want
to write and direct
a filipino myspace era rom-com ah
yes opening shot rearranging the top
eight
yes now you have to do it immediately
because someone's gonna steal it
i've already written it all right sorry
guys copyrighted
go [ __ ] yourself it's been done i wanna
bring myspace back
um that's mine it was so fun i peaked oh
my god but esther and i would fight to
see like where we're ranked
one or two you would just have to
rearrange this every week after each
episode you guys change
no i'm i feel submissive to kalila i
feel like she could be number one
although esther wouldn't even check that
would be what the annoying part is
esther wouldn't know where the [ __ ] she
was in my [ __ ] top eight i'm
literally
mad about even the idea because she
knows it's true look at her she would
have no [ __ ] clue where she was in my
coffee
and i would be taught by the way i'd be
the ninth and you know my top eight
would be like britney spears lady gaga
no it would be way worse than that we
know who it would be
carlos john
jay wolfe our fans our fans will be on
before me
what is your what is your bucket list
thing um
i here's the thing i really like
adventure and stuff but i don't have
specific ones i like to very
be very open to them and i usually just
say yes to things so
i would love to go spearfishing with you
i wanna i wanna do like water stuff i
haven't done them i went scuba diving a
long time ago i'd like to do that again
skydiving again i don't know there's
like a lot of things i want to do
i really like doing the things i've
already done
and i like of all the things you've
already done what was your most favorite
just like growing up in my house
[Laughter]
we like to call esther the adventure
slug from the group
i do it all over again but that's not
really a bucket list
i don't know hey girls we're taehyun
baker from philly
and so we just had a pretty easy breezy
question for you guys to answer
um we just wanted to know when was the
last time you guys started
and if you don't know what that means it
means you just [ __ ] and fart in your
pants
okay thanks love you guys bye you
couldn't be more off that you thought we
didn't know that
i mean we were lit three living sharks
in fact that was a name option
[Laughter]
sharp break the sharp breakers
i was at cold stone creamery in my
senior year of high school with my
sister we just had a really big meal
and i thought it was just a normal fart
i was actually wearing a skirt from
abercrombie
and the second it happened i know the
skirt was from urban outfitters
the second it happened i just knew like
something really bad happened
so i went across the way to mangiano's
and i checked my underwear
and i had i just threw it away i was
like this is
you know this is we're gonna take one
for the team and then just proceeded
and had my cold stone and the next day
at school
i was i just told everyone i was like
you guys so yeah i shoot my pants
yesterday did you throw your underwear
or did you um wash it
no no i threw it in the garbage i didn't
intend
not even a fart came out but just a
random
tight ball of poo fell out while i was
about to
learn to play tennis at um the vermont
canyon tennis court did you backhand it
were you like
why we hadn't even started i just was
just walking to the car i was like oh
i'm just gonna learn tennis today
and it was just god's way of telling me
you will never learn tennis [ __ ]
because like i swear to god it was like
a tight ball and it wasn't even that
small of a nugget
it was a considerably like it's a good
sized nugget it
with no warning no pain in my stomach no
fart impending
nothing lined up to come out a ball just
fell out of my butt and i just felt the
weight in my underwear oh and i was like
what is that and it wasn't a squish
squash
it was just a tight ball so i was like
what is that and when i pulled my
panties down
it rolled out so it was
a perfect crime yeah kind of and i don't
know i'm not going to pick that
did you ever [ __ ] in the pool oh no i
was one of the people that [ __ ] in the
pool my mom was like is that yours and i
was like no
you're cold brown i had to oh i was i
was concentrating
you know how much i loved you because
when there was cold brown there's no
swim practice
and i always think i was like who did
this when people throw the snickers bar
and they'd be like oh
the best day of my life that i was like
it's [ __ ] a snickers the best day of
my life lightning
lightning storm and code brown because
i'm like oh no practice
i have definitely sharded more recently
than this but this is my most epic
chart i found out i was opening for jim
norton
okay this is my big my big break i was
two years into comedy or something he's
opening he's performing in caroline's
which i am
now one of my first amazing experiences
on stage was at
caroline's in new york and i will be
there in august check andy letterman dot
com
okay so i get a call i'm in a coffee
shop i'm living in brooklyn it's like
five blocks from my house i get a coffee
my life is just regular i'm just an open
micro i just
go do five minute open mic sets in front
of a bunch of other people that hate me
comedians it's not a good life i get my
coffee i get a call
it's someone from caroline's and they go
jim norton has selected you
to be his opener this weekend in
caroline's i'm all of a sudden a
professional comedian
from the time i've grabbed this thing
i'm like oh my god and i was such a big
fan of jim
so and my dad was too so i was like so
excited that i was stepping out to
walk home and to call my dad and i
stepped out and i was like i'm gonna let
this fart out like
like life is good so i just i step
out and i [ __ ] my [ __ ] pants
i [ __ ] my pants and i'm like
so i call my dad and i'm like dad i have
news
[Laughter]
i'm opening for jim norton and i just
[ __ ] my pants and he goes
i'm so sick of you and hangs up on me
and i'm like what
i have to squish squash home five blocks
i'm like uh
what so then i call him back and i'm
like dad what the [ __ ] and he goes
you're messing with me you and your
mother i'm like what does mom have to do
this because
your mom just [ __ ] her pants too we [ __ ]
our pants at the exact same time
that's the power of jim norton okay
well i guess that has been an episode
with these
three fools uh if you guys liked what
you saw today
which we know you did use sickos like
this video
subscribe on youtube give us a review on
itunes do all the things make us happy
girls
we'll see you guys next time bye guys
you